okay we are
live and it's so
obnoxious when uh the internet just
freaking crashes on
okay cool we're going to
start
with repoing this experiment
okay so this was our
previous I back last one
here and then there
I think this was good about this is a
good reference
see this one has a fair bit of overhead
do
we'll try without the initialization as
well maybe the initialization is
screwing it up
now you got to remember right that
there's also a selection bias here so
the brown curve is like you ran a whole
bunch of experiments and then looking at
the most stable of them cuz if we looked
at the most stable one of this one it
also looked nice and
this is still either solved or very very
close to
solved with this run
go got Sol
score 62 yeah
yeah okay so this is also solved these
both solve solved at 100
Mil I'm going to take the scaling out
just in case and the
case do that doesn't even necessarily
mean that this is bad or anything it
just means that uh possibly the hyper
parameters don't agree with it we'll run
it like this
next we'll see what that
does these are the results we
need these are the results we need for
honestly this is starting to look on
par because if I just copied this right
we also have the other breakout
sweep from a while ago I believe this
was the good
one okay so this is the other breakout
sweep we have this parito
front right here we have solved in 279
seconds is the best and mind you there's
about a
20% overhead it looks
like uh that we've added with this extra
function
so and we're going to be able to remove
162 this portion of the curve looks
better which would suggest to me that
probably the whole curve is better
right these tend to be very
steep we're definitely going to have to
see what's going on over here
all right this is
something it's pretty close on the
I'm pretty content to just keep running
these experiments tonight
going to be
big be very big
this is kind of
wild to give you an idea of how
significant this would
be any reason why you implemented your
own Pito genetic sweep instead of other
Liv
libraries they don't have that algorithm
and mine's
better simply
enough they don't have the
algorithm my I code is better
as this seems more stable better also to
give you an idea of how substantial I
mean this is just like me fiddling with
research experiments right now but to
give you an an idea of how substantial
this would be uh if I have if I get this
working like across the
board and I match
J then this would be the first general
purpose like Drop in pretty much zero
cost Improvement to PO since
2017 this would be like the first major
algorithmic like general purpose
algorithmic Improvement to RL since 2017
what do they even have in Ray to
they even have anything good in here
now to their credit they have a lot of
the
algorithms I think ours is better
though but here's the funny thing right
you have all these libraries for this
here's my
code if we ignore the comments it's like
500 lines I think it's less than 500
lines if I remove these uh redundant
comments this is the new
algorithm all right this is Paro genetic
it's one
screen yeah I do require pyro for the
new algorithm because you need gen
gaussian processes but that's it
want to clean code then you use this
right you use our stuff we have the
shortest
dependencies puffer is the place to be
if you care about performance and
simplicity right if you care about tons
of tons and options and bells and
whistles puffer not the place for you
right but if you want the thing that
works as simple and as fast as possible
as
puffer puff up your reinforcement
learning today
I want things I can hack in well puffer
is very easy to hack because it is very
short by
puffer exactly they make it hard puer we
make it
easy why do difficult thing when easy
thing just is
so now this
works and the only thing I really need
to figure out is how to make this robust
to different um value prediction
Horizons that's all I need to sort
okay we'll see how this
goes they're kind of two things that
could happen here right one is that this
just doesn't work as well when you
increase the Horizon uh but what I'm
hoping is that there's just like a
startup period That's longer while it
figures out how to adjust the effective
Horizon
okay I'm trying to think if there's any
reason why it would be fundamentally
harder with longer
Horizon I don't think
so I wouldn't think so I play the
opposite it should be
it could just be the advantage function
being
silly if we're looking at initialization
versus Advantage
function probably Advantage function is
the place to look
right
Captain these are both G these are both
no G right here
the only thing we haven't figured out
yet is how to make it robust when you
have longer value prediction
Horizons what made it so much faster
hyper pram sweeps we had to redo
hyperparameter
optimization I mean we still have to
do yeah I know it's huge
right the thing is we still have to do
like major major experimentation but
this is what I'm saying like if you want
to get involved with the experiment side
I'm fixing
RL like this is not like little like
shitty research we are actually going to
fix RL this
year right like literally as soon as you
point puffer lip in the general
direction of something and you do
research at this speed with like any
degree of competence stuff
solved I mean literally if you were
running this on uh on cleanar you would
be waiting weeks for these
results sp3 weeks for these results you
wouldn't even be able to implement the
thing as easily because like you'd have
to go dig through sp3 algorithm code
good got to go now you let me know when
you're around I briefed Spencer
already whenever you want to get
involved we'll be here
okay so this is very nice and
stable um it underperforms
majorly we're going to figure out why
why
yeah so okay this is a nice stable curve
it's just there's like some noise or
something so we'll figure this out
this so we are setting the scale to
zero Beyond 32 and we see what this
changes
so still lagging
right now the question I have is is this
going to be on par with the
original or
not looks like it's a bit steep steeper
but it's very
early so essentially here right
if this doesn't work if this works on
par with this then the error is coming
from the NL law
somehow and if it does work then we're
set and if it's in between then I don't
know
is evening algorithm
Dev and mostly a bunch of
experiments
H we'll see what this is on par with
so I've had results before where it
doesn't seem like doing this alone fixes
the
problem so if that were the
case then the only other place the
problem can come from is the NL loss
right okay so you know what we'll do
next
is we will uh we'll mask the
loss so if this doesn't give us on power
performance we'll mask the loss and that
should have to give us onar
performance and then maybe we'll do it
the other way around so we mask uh one
and not the
other so this just
here I unfortunately we do need to do
the whole runs on
these they are slow
I'd really like to know about this 34%
though presumably I just have to find a
way to make the scyon
chilling I guess I can just think about
some plant for this
so I don't think it's going to be be
quite time to merge this yet I still
want to test the hyper Prim
sweeps independently not on
this
yeah so we're going to refine the hyper
pram sweep
stuff a little
bit breakout seems like a very good end
for biddings with stuff
trains pretty
fast sweeps don't take too long
anymore so probably I'm going to play
with the last remaining things that I
wanted to play with on hyper pram sweeps
over
there and
then we'll probably start running
benchmarks
on well we'll merge that into this in
parallel we'll start running sweeps on
both for all the different MS
I think the new sweep algorithm is
efficient enough we probably don't need
200 experiments per end probably only
need
100 that'll also give us good evidence
on this algorithm
what would it imply if this is slightly
above the other
loss oh if this is slightly above the
other one it just implies that at least
some small amount of the
of the performance drop is attributable
to the computation of the advantage
function that's all that
yeah which would make
sense and then NL is the other part of
it but the thing is I don't know how we
fix
NL like why would that be a
problem why would Computing an NL loss
over
more was it gaan negative log likelihood
why would Computing that
over larger
sample create more error I don't think
that's how the law should work
knowing I still have to run the full
thing for the end state
but how's this going in the
meantime
oo 334 in 100
seconds for reference this is about how
well um original like sp3 and clean ARL
does in I think an hour or two
optimal for the folks watching
all this is on
puff. including the latest commits all
the dev branches are public you can play
with all this uh the results right as
they come
out start the repo if you do really
helps me
out pretty much I just track stars on
the repo and kind of X
followers it's pretty much it
for growth of puffer
lib reason I have to wait for this whole
thing is because the end State sometimes
it can jump up at the end quite a
bit this one looks to have been pretty
stable oh no we get the spike at the end
a little bit
what
happened in
it's other way
around
32 there we go
so this should be identical to the
original
run this is meant as a like a hard check
on the horizon if something screw is
happening
cuz now I have Horizon 128 but I have
everything masked to be the same as uh
as
32 so if this doesn't
work and yeah some just really
screwy and then that's most likely just
a bug so we just have to go hunt the
bug given that it looks like there is
one we can start looking for
it okay the first 32 elements and this
is a mean
so
oh you're stupid
things you make dumb mistakes well at
least I make dumb mistakes when I've
been doing this
for know most of the day
it I still don't know if this will
match we will see
loss it could literally be a scaling
issue right
let's see what this does before we make
any conclusion on that but it could
literally be a scaling
issue if most of the signal is in the
first spot of the like the first chunk
of the loss and we take a
in and wouldn't think it should be some
over the last Dimension though right
that would be
it it sucks that there's hardly any any
RL news on X anymore like everybody's
just gone and done llms
RL if only people had AR Tech this is
like a fun gimmick it would be so easy
to get RL working on an end like
this it's a fun gimmick but these don't
actually you know these
D like nobody's going to like look at a
thing through their phone and be like oh
wow it renders in 3D on my phone on the
camera we got 309 and 30
that any
good oh yeah that looks on par with the
other
runs still have to run the whole damn
thing
issue question is what do we do if it is
a SC scaling
some a Thum doesn't work either that's
still doesn't scale
perfectly I want to fiddle with the
scales a little bit
run that's got to just be drift right
that's showing up is
better yeah it can't possibly just be
better it's the same thing as
before yeah there you go it's just some
Drift But if it's on par
and then we'll have to just figure out
if it's scaling or
scaling it can't be credit assignment
right
no there really should be no
way for that loss to be messed
up unless it's a network capacity issue
but I don't think that makes sense
here oh here's a
dip but this is not uncommon right the
other experiment dipped as well that's
not I mean that's not a killer here it's
already back up
I'm going to call this curve a match
because this one bump is like common and
the end Point's the same the general
shape is the
same and make sure the end Point's
actually the
same I do wonder what it is that causes
this type of thing though right it's
like temporary policy collapse and
rebound this can't just be random noise
this is too big for random noise random
noise is on the scale of like these
little jaggies you see here this is like
genuine
good okay that's the repo with 128 with
everything
masked provided this is not going to
screw up
here I mean even still it's like it's
there so we're good so
the this is the
Repro and then we'll do this will just
be mean of zero
do
sum over
32 so we're going to try this
one so this is going to take the same
scale and basically just assume that the
last elements don't contribute
here there is no Norm on
vloss there's a
clip and not a
solved we're not expecting this to
match we're just expecting this to do
something in
it's
slower again all this has to do is land
in the
middle and then if this does land in the
middle then what we do is we take some
sort of
normalization and we throw some
normalization on
something we still have to do this
without the clipping and then if
if this all works then it's just pure
normalization is the
issue there might still have to be some
clipping we'll
see but essentially if we're able to
match it means that we should be able to
have it should be Horizon independent
you should be able to give it a longer
Horizon it'll either do the same or will
do
better CU longer Horizon environments
will make use of more of of the value
it's flattened
out we'll see terminal
Behavior a lot of progress oh
yeah potentially revolutionary progress
for the
field if this works this will be
the first major algorithmic like first
major general purpose algorithmic
advancement in RL since
2017 preliminary results are very
strong preliminary results are very
strong just a few things we have to
fiddle with
still this curve is a little
weird it was matching
it slow
down well again we didn't expect to be
perfect so that's kind of okay
the only thing we need to do is to be
better than the bottom set of
bonus s you would have been working
through save material for
this so the
um the thing to keep in mind fer for
loads it gets blown up every time we
fire it's
funny there's already good generative
models for CAD um the thing to keep in
mind for RL right is you're looking for
interactive
processes you're looking for like for
processes that have a clear like action
to be taken to modify the simulation
feedback
signal well no but I wouldn't
necessarily class it as an RL problem
either I don't know people have gotten
some stuff out of
them if you're just designing holders
for things I think you can just do
that doesn't take much AI really doesn't
take any
AI okay there we go
little bit unstable but generally pretty
good
structure if you have a thing that
you're simulating is well I'd have to
look at it and see how I would cast it
as a
problem it produces
microwaves through some Russian name
effect
produces blue light in nuclear
reactor I didn't know that was a
thing electrons moving faster
than wait electrons moving faster than
the speed of
light electrons can move faster than the
speed of
light wait is there a thing that is
there actually a loophole in speed of
light
is there a speed of light loophole
nobody told me
about this is very very close so I'll
call this a
match this is so darn close
right in
oh in the material so there there so
there isn't an exploit on the absolute
speed of
light there's nothing that goes
faster damn it I was hoping you were
going to tell me there's a loophole
loophole see because there if there is
any sort of speed of light
loophole I bet that we're going to be
able to have like faster than light
travel and stuff and that would be
pretty cool
we get to have some sci-fi
stuff if you can produce anyim
matter make an engine that gets close to
the speed of
light you would feel no
time yeah but then you would get the
like shitty version of sci-fi right in
which like you don't feel any time pass
but everybody else feels years of time
now we want the Sci-Fi version where it
just freaking works and uh you and then
we can just like hop all over the
universe whenever we want that's the
cool
one don't think I can crack that one
yeah we'll wait for AI to crack that
one I think ai's got to delete has got
to deliver us at least one crazy sci-fi
thing before we really take get too
seriously we at least have it has to
give us like one crazy thing straight
out of sci-fi
well hopefully not that
sci-fi I'm thinking more um you know
culture series or
I need to
focus
well you don't take it too
seriously the thing is it's possible now
is pretty boring you got to give
something you got to have something to
get you to get up in the morning right
work would we like to check the number
of Dev hours streamed this
month it's quite a lot
less I wonder if we should also try this
with the
clipping the clipping should be the same
shouldn't
it I mean I guess we'll look at
it clipping should be the
same want to try that as well a lot of
just manual experiments
today when it's for something this big I
don't mind it
how big of a
jump so let's say that it performs
exactly the same as generalized
Advantage estimation okay let's say that
that's the bar that we get it to work
exactly as well as the previous
one you
add you just make your existing you
change this form of your existing loss
terms you make the loss
layer bigger but that should be
essentially free and you delete two very
fiddly hyper parameters from the
algorithm you no longer have to sweep
two hyper parameters
thing no it doesn't cut down the compute
on a 1 million parameter run it cuts
down the hyperparameter search so that
means a few things first of all you have
to run fewer experiments in order to get
optimal hyper parameters and second it
is much much more likely that you will
able be able to use the same hyper
parameters across many different
environments and have it perform quite
well out of the
box so this would be a large step
forward for out of the box reinforcement
learning pong to other games may be pong
to other Sims
entirely you cut out I think it
the probably the second and the third
most fiddly hyper parameters in
RL so you cut out two of the top
three you know most annoying hyper
parameters in
Lambda you can tune a hyper parameter
but you can't tune a
can't tune a
puffer Public Service Announcement do
not take Puffer fish out of the
water inflating them with air kills them
do not do that they're very friendly
creatures
I saw one
snorkeling like uh a month month and a
half
okay so this is better than the other
ones but
needs maybe
clipping we'll try clipping
next I was on vacation I wasn't
sparkling in
Florida I think in Florida you can
technically find some manties though
that would be
cool but I can also literally just like
take a 30 second walk outside and just
see alligators just chilling by the side
of a
pond freaking like 8 foot alligator just
chilling there waiting to Chomp
protected that could be a winers worth a
jerky and a new pair of
shoes and one last thing to worry about
chomping you
mil my question is is this going to
track the previous run or is this going
to track this one up
here I would think that it should have
to track the one up there with the
clipping we will see though
I think I'd argue that this is actually
simpler to implement than
um the original po as
well generalized Advantage estimation is
really awkward to
implement this is a lot easier I'd say
would you ever try Fugu no leave the
puffers
alone leave the puffer fish
alone they're very friendly
think if there's anything I can do on on
this here
don't think there's any great way I can
always optimize the
picture there was a post on this earlier
that yeah like if you go anywhere with
SF you can just get a house like a 1K
mortgage on it
want would you ever go
where to somewhere in the middle of
nowhere instead of SF I'm current l in
Florida not exactly the tech capital of
the world but I'm building whatever
right uh I've been there I don't plan on
going
back it's kind of just a shitty and
dangerous city at the moment
I don't know how many more Founders have
to get attacked in broad daylight before
it's like yeah this is just a stupid
place to
be I'll be spending a good chunk of the
summer and Paulo Alto
cleaner
y now Pao Alto is nice Mountain View is
nice I mean honestly a whole bunch of
areas are
well let it finish to be sure but it
doesn't seem like it
so the fact that that doesn't mitigate
is kind of
32 like
I should be able to print
stupid think what you're doing is really
cool AI Master student SMU learning a
lot from your content thank you at the
moment it's mostly just chill and run
experiments but if you just got here the
uh particular experiments were running
right now could be a particularly major
breakthrough let's say
this would be
a well the first general purpose
enhancement to PO since
2017 he goes through the
roof I mean I had a I think I had a hell
of an ego and undergrad as
well I to be fair I was kind of doing
all right doing all right by then
already
people you better damn well be right
though if you're going to be arrogant
you better be
I had one good friend do
r2c I don't know where he went after
that I he's probably in the Air Force
now
oh hang on there's just a ton of
variants in these isn't
now I think there might just be a ton of
variant that's a good data point
uh chain of command well I guess I
wouldn't it's not we don't have any
links to military with my stuff right so
there's not really a chain of command or
anything
can you explain to me how it is
that the devices that you would make
would be able to be
like
sold commercially to like Farmers or
whatever if you need to detonate
C4 every time you have to charge
one of the students have
expanded acoss many
domains that's
cool I had a fair bit of breath in uh in
ml in my like early 20s I had quite a
bit of breath but now I'm pretty
specialized in what I
do I'm good at picking new stuff up I'm
pretty
specialized and uh yeah just by random
chance that's perfect learning curve
right there that's uh a perfect like
that's right on par with j
military search do more
industry like your company that can do
it
all but is
there I mean are they like you charge
the capacitor and it's like a single use
thing or
I'm just trying to figure how does it
work if to recharge it you need to
detonate
C4 is that a
thing applications that run
H so presumably you're not constant
detonating
C4 unless you
are constant C4 detonation
Ed rame or em Harden drones that's
cool that is definitely
cool if you like drones then RL is the
way that you would uh train
the uh the maneuvering of drones RL is
the way you do
it it's like a perfect RL problem
ktic
yeah highest energy
density limits
required on
navigation no no no I mean like if you
have a 100 drones okay and you want the
100 drones to be like perfectly coord at
in a way that's completely super human
and above any ability that we could
program algorithmically like directly
you use
RL that'd be a fun thing to work on to
be
honest we should do that we should do I
mean I could even sci-fi it a little bit
up and I could just make like a
swarm ship Sim that'd be
course if my primary goal were money I
wouldn't be doing this at least not in
the way that I'm doing
it it is a goal but it is the secondary
goal
money will
come money will come
how do I get on get in on this swarm Sim
that's the thing you literally just
start doing stuff you just start
building
stuff there's no gatekeeping here here
I'll show you one
second
okay
so here I built this
environment I built this environment I
built this
environment this one this one this one
this one this one this one this one this
one and this one were all just people
contributors who showed up and were like
hey I want to build a thing how about
this and I said go for it and then I
just you know gave input along the way
and
helped but yeah literally you just start
building
Sims and then puffer makes it
fast we have all the resources you need
on this
stuff it's much easier than it
looks you don't even you don't have to
do like complicated like you don't have
to even do like physics Sim at the level
of the propellers and like the air flow
and all that like literally if you just
did uh like ships in 3D space having to
like coordinate to do a thing
effectively
yeah I mean this is pretty much how it
works right I get dozens and dozens of
people asking me like how I get involved
in RL I tell everybody look you
literally just show up and build these
Sims and then the ones who stick around
become you know active contributors and
uh they get Hardware access active
contributors get access to our hardware
and I do code reviews and you know they
get a lot of good
information hey I invest time in people
who invest time and puffer that's how
the open source
works it is remarkably remarkably easy
to get involved you just put in a little
bit of the
time ultimately we want this to be a
quality open source stuff just need
people building these environments and
testing stuff actually two of the
contributors now have done so much stuff
on Puffer that I'll be onboarding them
onto some of the more science side stuff
that I do done one onboarding already
understand like does this just work I
doubt this works right this is probably
tiny open source waiting on first
citation did you just publish
several I don't even have the Google
Scholar profile I'm pretty sure
no bil's published RL in the field yeah
rl's hard
well it depends what the search
Dimension
is I can probably do better than genetic
there's a value clip but there's no
value Norm it looks like
genetic algorithms are much easier to
get working than to than RL which is why
a lot of people just start with them but
they don't work anywhere near as
well like they're easier to implement
but they don't work anywhere near as
well
oh you know
what I wonder if it's just
um wonder if it's just
this no I wouldn't think so honestly but
maybe
the thing about yet is you can know the
math way better than I do and the
engineering will still bite you
let's see how this goes cuz I think I
might have figured that
out could just be the masking it was
wrong I would doubt it but
maybe this doesn't seem like it matches
the YOLO curve here
but run this I'm going to set up the
sweeps and go to bed
that we're going to shred
this we're going to absolutely shred
this these are my top writing tips
number one before you start writing any
essay I would recommend drafting five ad
power itself is defined as energy
divided by time and so pulse power is
the engineering of taking and
accumulating energy over a longer
duration and releasing it over a shorter
duration and so if I take a single Jewel
of energy and I discharge that in 1
second it's one watt if I take that same
Jewel of energy and I discharge it in a
nanc that's now a gwatt and there's a
lot of very interesting physics that can
occur there a lot of things that are
very critical to National Security and
so we execute research with uh various
Partners in the department of energy and
the uh Department of Defense so the
United States right now is in a critical
situation regarding uh Workforce
capability in impulse power and uh
electromagnetic pulse Sciences at the
end of the day training students is the
the the sole purpose of our job and
there's a need that is not being met by
the existing infrastructure so the ree
Technology Center is is very unique in
that it's an off-site location it's a a
former Air Force Base it has access
through uh active runways and things
that would allow uh Department of
Defense Partners uh private contractors
and so on to fly in assets and we would
have the capability to test uh critical
systems and components for their
electromagnetic vulnerabilities we're a
very techn technologically advanced
society and uh from a DOD perspective
we're a very uh technologically advanced
military force
and uh this is something that our
adversaries are uh very cognizant of and
so if we look at other adversary Nations
they are developing Technologies to that
would threaten our our Electronics
capability and so understanding our
vulnerabilities to the electromagnetic
spectrum is one part of it and then the
other part is developing a capability to
threaten other people's electronic
[Music]
capabilities well
I mean yes I get the I got the gist of
that from our
conversation
before and that's the very high level of
it yeah so this one doesn't
match okay so there's going to have to
be some sort of Norm
I'm trying to think where I can run
this
fgg a full rebuild for some
reason it's fine
okay cool that will now run you have two
active sweeps
running we will see what we get out of
these by
morning bunch of other work to do this
week as well
there's very good progress happening and
just got to keep it up um so for the
couple folks still
watching
puff. start the GitHub join Discord
we're almost a th here to get involved
if you're looking for Content got a Blog
right here with a quick start guide and
some Cutting Edge
stuff got services for
companies it's all open source still you
can follow me on X for more content
almost 7K here it's all RL
stuff all right I'm going to get some
sleep night folks and I will be back
probably for